ma sorry you know that feeling when you
play a game or you wash your TV series
and you get so lost in it that you
forget that there's an outside world and
once you finish it you just you're left
with an emptiness and feeling of what
[ __ ] do I do now with my life well I had
that this week and I just came out of it
and then I realized it was Friday and I
need to make a Friday video and I have
no aspirations in life anymore that's
what I'm talking to you right now hey at
least I'm honest I've been playing
blood-borne there's gonna be a lot of
editing to do but it's gonna be a
[ __ ] awesome series um I think it was
a really gonna like it I just feel so
empty
you know hashtag relatable
oh yeah there's there's one thing I
wanted to do for a while
thank you for thirty-five million seven
hundred and forty nine thousand five
hundred and fifty eight thousand
subscribers and bros that number in
particular really means a lot to me I
waited so long for that number and exact
that number but yeah when I was lost in
the world of video games this week I
realized that it's my job to play my
favorite game that's just so [ __ ]
awesome I owe it all to your breath I
went all to all three million thirty
five million three hundred five [ __ ] I
don't know it makes me really really
happy that I can do that I have no
strength to put any effort in today's
it's not gonna happen so you're just
gonna get this
I got nothing um should be ended here I
think I think we should probably do that
all right what is it that great okay
thank you and I'm sorry about this video
and I will see you tomorrow when I
figured out what I'm gonna do next I
agree in there gross
thank you for being there I'm watching
my [ __ ] it makes me happy and I will see
you in the next one you ready for the
brofist all right bro fish